I am uh so looking forward to the new
Beverly Hills Cop
um because you're in it and I know that
it has to be good if you're coming back
to this role um what was it that finally
said I'm gonna make another one what
what what finally got you to do it uh
Jerry Bruckheimer the original producer
when he got involved and he started
developing the script and he knew what
Beverly Hills Cop is supposed to be uh
when he got back involved that's what
that's when it all started to come
together as we tried for years and years
maybe 10 12 years to to then I must have
read five or six different scripts and
it was never right in the studio was
like let's go here it is it was like no
it's just that Jerry Bruckheimer got
back in there you know and he knows his
[ __ ] and he put it together he did Top
Gun just last year and the Bad Boys is
Jerry Brown or so we have that same
brain behind Beverly Hills Cop and
he put it he put all the pieces in place
that were required for us to make a
great movie and I'm excited for people
to see it it's really hard to make
though
uh because because axle Foley is 21 and
I'm not 20. I'm not 21.
that's a long time ago and it's a really
physical movie and you know I had to do
some physical stuff and I know Tom
Cruise likes to do physical stuff but uh
you started off the interview but I like
to be on the couch I don't like to be
jumping over and shooting and running
and I had to do some jumping and
shooting and running and as a result you
know I had a knee brace at the end of
the movie had a knee brace and my back
was messed up and all that but but the
movie is going to be you know
special